bueno
[Música]
hola bienvenido a la revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo mientras en
rusia está prohibido informar sobre los
ataques a ucrania una plataforma permite
enviar mensajes de texto o llamar a una
o varias personas dentro del país para
contarles qué es lo que está sucediendo
en territorio ucraniano esto es posible
a través de 1920 punto int un sitio web
creado por un grupo de programadores
cuyo objetivo según dicen es eludir la
censura y asegurarse de que los rusos
permanezcan conectados con la realidad
france24 logró entrevistar a uno de sus
integrantes empezamos
las medidas drásticas que el gobierno de
rusia tomó en contra de los medios de
comunicación independientes y
extranjeros generó el surgimiento de
iniciativas que intentan paliar la
censura es el caso de 1920 punto en una
plataforma con la que cualquier persona
puede enviar mensajes o llamar a
ciudadanos en suelo ruso para contarles
qué es lo que está pasando en territorio
ucraniano la página es administrada por
square 303 un grupo de programadores que
dicen estar coordinados desde polonia su
objetivo es luchar contra la censura
digital del presidente vladimir putin y
asegurarse de que el pueblo ruso
permanezca conectado con el mundo y la
realidad de lo que rusia está haciendo
en ucrania ya que el territorio ruso no
se permite hablar sobre guerra o
invasión y en los medios estatales no se
muestran los estragos de la ofensiva y
sólo se refieren a ella como una
operación especial
la página a través de la cual se envían
los mensajes de texto es muy sencilla de
manejar al entrar a en 1920 punto y le
dará la opción de enviar un mensaje de
texto directo oa través de un whatsapp
un correo electrónico o incluso hacer
una llamada si es un mensaje de texto
por ejemplo le aparecerá en la parte
superior el número de teléfono de
destino y debajo un texto predeterminado
escrito en ruso para saber qué dice
puede copiarlo y pasarlo a google
traductor si quiere enviar un mensaje
distinto puede irse a la opción new text
y éste cambiará hay varios tipos de
mensajes como los que ven en pantalla
una vez enviado se establecerá una
comunicación con el destinatario si
ambos así lo desean
en france 24 logramos comunicarnos con
uno de los integrantes de squat 303
quien se hace llamar hanson back por
razones de seguridad habló con el rostro
cubierto y nos pidió que distorsionará
mos su voz nos contó que este proyecto
tuvo su origen cuando vio a las calles
de polonia llenas de refugiados
ucranianos y sintió la necesidad de
ayudar pero que tuvo cierta inspiración
en radio free europe una organización de
radiodifusión que fue financiada por
estados unidos y que transmitía mensajes
al bloque soviético de europa durante la
guerra fría él recuerda particularmente
durante los años 80 cuando el movimiento
solidaridad en polonia zanjó el camino
hacia el fin del comunismo
hay cursos
no entiendo lo valioso que es poder
escuchar las voces fuera del pasado los
polacos son esclavos del comunismo
durante el día tenían que pretender que
estaban de acuerdo con la línea del
partido comunista pero en las noches la
mayoría de nosotros solía escuchar radio
free europe un día de repente nos
levantamos y actualmente vivimos en un
país libre y queremos hacer lo mismo por
los rusos
zumba que también ofreció cifras del
impacto que habían logrado al momento de
grabar esta entrevista aseguran tener
una robusta base de datos de personas en
rusia
en el momento probablemente tenemos la
mayoría de los números de teléfonos de
rusia
con seguridad tenemos cada correo
electrónico que le pertenece a la gente
de este país
ah
está creciendo rápidamente gracias a
ustedes los periodistas tenemos más y
más gente luchadores de la libertad
guerreros cibernéticos de distintos
países uniéndose nos ayer anunciamos que
30 millones de mensajes fueron enviados
sigue creciendo empezamos con un
servidor hace 13 días en el momento
tenemos 16 y todavía sigue siendo
insuficiente
el proceso ha enfrentado una serie de
desafíos por un lado lograr que la
población rusa responda a los mensajes
siendo conscientes de que están siendo
vigilados y por otro que no todos los
que reciben son opositores del kremlin
cuando empezamos publicamos una
herramienta para enviar mensajes de
texto y notamos que muchas de las
personas allá en rusia aparecían
asustadas de responder porque saben que
su gobierno controla las comunicaciones
pero luego también habilitamos la opción
de enviar mensajes desde whatsapp luego
emails y hoy las llamadas en el momento
puedo decir que en el caso de whatsapp e
emails somos más eficientes porque en
whatsapp a la gente no le da miedo
responder y vemos que más y más personas
han empezado un diálogo y esa es nuestra
meta básicamente al final del día nos
gustaría construir millones de puentes
pequeños de comunicación pequeños
canales de comunicación entre la gente
del mundo libre y los que están en rusia
para que les hagan saber la verdad
acerca del mundo que les permitan
iniciar conversaciones que les permitan
compartir sus puntos de vista a veces
estas conversaciones no son fáciles a
veces alguien puede ofenderte pero es un
proceso imaginemos que vives en un país
esclavizado que están lavando tu cerebro
todo el día no es posible cambiar sus
formas de pensar o sus perspectivas con
un mensaje necesitamos más tiempo pero
vamos por un buen camino y vemos que más
y más gente en rúsia responde
según johnson white pronto incorporarán
más herramientas para que más personas
en rusia puedan sentirse seguras de
comunicarse con el resto del mundo a
través de otros canales hasta aquí
revista digital recuerde que si quiere
repetir esta u otra misión de nuestro
programa lo puede hacer a través de
nuestra página web www puntos francia 24
punto com
[Música]